so let's get to it with our first award
and - presented a beautiful actress last
year she went home with two of the best
looking men in Hollywood Oscar and Alec
Baldwin lucky baby honey please welcome
last year's Supporting Actress Best
Supporting Actress MS Kim Basinger
thank you the nominees for Best Actor in
a supporting role are James Coburn
in affliction Robert Duvall in a civil
action Ed Harris in The Truman Show
geoffrey rush in shakespeare and loved
Billy Bob Thornton in a simple plan
and the Oscar goes to James Coburn
the Magnificent Seven and our man Flint
this is his first Academy Award
you
my mama Wow
you know I've been around here I've been
working and doing this work for like I
have over half my life and I finally got
one right I guess this key some of them
you do for money some of them do for
love this this is a love child Paul
Schrader put together a paulandnic
actually put together affliction I mean
it was a beautiful script we had an
extraordinary cast Nick [ __ ] Spacek
Willem Dafoe
Mary Beth hurt and a screenplay second
to none I'd like to thank all of those
people plus C Linder then the Riesling
produced it for us
Largo paid for it
aha Lionsgate released it I'd like to
thank Ellie Elkins my manager and and
Bobby let my agent my publicists Delson
in wasteman ah she said I'd like to say
thanks to all the people up in Santa
Barbara where I'm working on a thing
called the Atticus Thank You gang for
giving me Monday off uh listen my kids I
say thank you my kid wait a minute wait
a minute I got to say something else
here this for my beautiful wife Paula
that's its
she finally got to come to the Academy
Awards this is for you baby